faces of the missing because of russia's
war
this is vlad he's 29 his mother hasn't
heard from him since the start of march
she shows us where her only child
disappeared from a village just outside
kiev
he'd been driving with his stepmother
when russian soldiers opened fire
it happened here
they fled down this path
but tetiana said the stepmother was shot
in the jaw and shoulder he was shot in
the leg
she passed out and when she came round
vlad was gone
there
[Music]
[Music]
she's not alone
russia's invasion has torn apart
thousands of families
loved ones feared buried in rubble
forcibly removed to russia or just
unable to make contact
ukraine's police have received more than
7 000 reports of missing people since
the start of the war
only about half have been located
inga and andre disappeared on the 4th of
march
inga's mother takes us to where they'd
been staying
the couple had been living with a
neighbor while doing up their own home
this is all that's left of his place she
doesn't know if they were in at the time
or at their house next door do you
believe your daughter is still alive
um
yesterday
foreign
[Laughter]
victor died of heart failure while his
town was occupied by russians
his body only found after his family
visited five morgues
hope still flickering though that others
will yet be found alive
debra haynes sky news keeve